bienvenue André
installez-vous parce que il part tout de
suite il me quitte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a 3 ans vous avez presque pas
changé ouais presque pas j'ai une
nouvelle veste ah c'est ça
tout va bien super
tu as une toute mon frère
c'est la tête d'un gars qui sait que
c'est mort pour lui l'hiver s'installe
en France et un premier test cette
semaine pour le système électrique avec
un pic attendu ce jeudi
75,6 gigas watts devrait être consommé
selon les dernières prévisions
un pic qui aurait pu être encore plus
élevé sans la baisse de consommation
d'électricité observée ces dernières
semaines les particuliers notamment font
des efforts cette mini centrale
hydroélectrique Patrick Barbier en 2020
et depuis en gros on a plus de factures
d'électricité quoi parce que parce qu'on
l'auto l'autoproduit cet équipement
permet aujourd'hui d'alimenter la mairie
la salle des fêtes ainsi que tous
l'éclairage public il nous reste
quelques gigawatts c'est vraiment pas
beaucoup s'il commence à faire vraiment
froid là on pourra avoir un problème de
sécurité d'approvisionnement selon cette
expert une alerte éco-watt orange
synonyme de tension sur le réseau
pourrait être déclenché lundi prochain
jour attendu d'un nouveau pic de
consommation les spécialistes les
experts les techniciens tous de
Jean-Bernard le heavy à Yves bréchet en
passant par Loïc Lefranc Prigent tous
disent la même chose incompétence
idéologies faiblesse et les mensonges
cynisme et des informations sur la ligne
directrice des gouvernants d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui covid énergie même combat
le Masque et la bougie sont attendus
pour Noël Fabrice le D on y va tout
droit quand on court à l'échec dans le
Midi
l'inquiétude des patients placés sous
respirateurs artificiels et hospitalisés
à domicile ils ont appris hier par la
voix du porte-parole Bénédicte qu'ils
pourront comme tous les Français être
ponctuellement privés d'électricité cet
hiver
réagir à ce que vous disiez ils sont
délestables ces personnes là ils sont
non prioritaires si je peux me permettre
de le dire ainsi le président de la
République à cette semaine voulu se
montrer rassurant vous risquez vraiment
clarifier les choses
pas de panique ce débat est absurde
étape absurde le rôle des autorités
publiques des entreprises publiques ça
n'est pas de transférer la peur ni de
gouverner par la peur le rôle du
gouvernement des ministres des
opérateurs c'est de faire leur travail
pour fournir de l'énergie c'est tout et
ensuite c'est d'appeler chacun la
responsabilité pour qu'il y ait de la
sobriété c'est pas de commencer à faire
peur aux gens avec des scénarios
absurdes et des choses comme j'ai
entendu ces dernières heures stop à tout
ça en gros jamais un gouvernement nous
aura autant saoulé avec la lutte contre
les fake news et il monte du matin au
soir c'est un délire mais vraiment il
monte du matin et au soir et après ils
vont il y a un moment quand même il
manque du matin le sorcier avec son
bâton de pluie et ben il commandait aux
éléments de venir sauf que le sorcier
contrairement aux hommes politiques il
avait obligation de résultats si au bout
de trois jours il y avait pas la pluie
son bâton de cul iOS le carré enfin bref
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
sortie hier de la Coupe du monde de
football les Japonais n'ont pas tout
perdu à Lyon pour la deuxième année
consécutive c'est un chef venu du pays
du soleil levant qui a remporté la 13ème
coupe du meilleur pâté croûte de quoi
consoler les Japonais qui hier ont perdu
en 8e de finale de Coupe du monde avec
eux
du monde ou de gagner le championnat du
pâté de foot
je suis niveau
alors pas besoin de traduction pour
savoir
où ils les encouragent alors ils les
encouragent impossible de ne pas
remarquer Ivana Knoll les jours de match
de la Croatie cette supportrice de 30
ans fait sensation depuis le début de la
Coupe du monde dans les stades et sur
les réseaux sociaux sont compte
Instagram atteint désormais un million
et demi d'abonnés avec ses mini jupes
décolletés à damis rouge et blanc
Ivana Knoll défi ouvertement les règles
vestimentaires des organisateurs qui
demandent aux visiteurs de couvrir leurs
épaules et genoux les Lions de la classe
sont en quart de finale du Mondial et
regardez cette folie ce soir à Marrakech
les Marocains ont été exceptionnels
héroïques tout à l'heure face à
l'Espagne et le Maroc est très fort
l'Espagne j'ai vu que c'était des
chèvres
mais c'est des chèvres arrêtez j'adore
les Espagnols que je m'entraîne avec des
Espagnols toute la journée bah c'est des
chèvres c'est des chèvres aujourd'hui
c'est des chèvres
pour le moment les cathares de la
laissent s'habiller comme elle le veut
et certains se sont même fait penser en
train de la photographier paraît-il que
c'est pour dénoncer
l'amour est dans le slam Laurent il
paraît que vous cherchez un amour oui
alors attention l'amour est dans le slam
alors vous voulez qu'il soit comment
alors gentil ça c'est mieux après drôle
ok
intelligent OK et avec un petit peu de
sous ah si c'est possible c'est bien de
l'assumer cela ressemble à un
distributeur de billets classiques à une
nuance près celui-ci affiche le solde de
votre compte en banque à la vue de tous
en plus il établit un classement des
utilisateurs en fonction de leur
richesse cette machine à flatter
l'orgueil et l'ego est une installation
artistique dans une galerie d'art à
Miami et le concept a trouvé son public
notamment DJ Diplo un temps en tête avec
plus de 3 millions de dollars